لذا ، لنتحدث سارة عن
الأهمية العسكرية لهذه المنطقة حتى يعرف الناس
المنطقة التي نتحدث عنها هنا
نتحدث عن جنوب أوكرانيا
يمكنني الضغط عليها الآن على وجه التحديد على
النهر يمكنك رؤية النهر يتدفق
هنا هذا هو السد  وهذا هو
هاريسون تلك المدينة الواقعة في الجنوب التي
تسيطر عليها أوكرانيا الآن للحصول على
نقطة مرجعية هنا محطة الطاقة النووية
تقع فوق النهر من السد وهذا هو السبب في أن
الناس لا يعتقدون أنها مصدر قلق كبير
في الوقت الحالي ولكن عندما تتحدث  حول
الأهمية العسكرية لهذا
أكثر من ذلك بكثير ، يمكنك أن ترى أن نهر ديبرو
هو حرفياً الخط الفاصل بين
إقليم هيل الأوكراني وأراضي
الاحتلال الروسي في الجنوب ، حيث
كان الروس في شبه جزيرة القرم لعدة
سنوات وقد احتلوا هذه المنطقة
باللون الأحمر  الآن لمدة عام ينضم إلي للحديث
عما يعنيه كل هذا المحلل العسكري في سي إن إن المتقاعد العقيد
سيدريك لايتون في سلاح الجو ، لذا سيدريك هذه هي
الأراضي الروسية المحتلة هنا
حيث تسيطر أوكرانيا ، كيف يتم
تدمير هذه المنطقة اللعينة
هنا تغمرها المياه.  على وجه الخصوص ، كيف
يؤثر ذلك على الهجوم المضاد
الذي نتوقع جميعًا أن يأتي أو ربما
بدأ بالفعل من أوكرانيا ،
نعم ، ستكون هذه
مشكلة كبيرة لكلا الجانبين في الواقع وكما
سمعت في تقرير سام ، هناك
تأثير على روسيا  جانبًا أيضًا ولكن
بالنسبة للأوكرانيين ، سيكون هذا
كبيرًا لأنهم ربما اعتمدوا على
قدرتهم على عبور نهر نيبرو ، كما
تعلمون باستخدام المركبات البرمائية حتى
يتمكنوا بالفعل من الذهاب إلى
المناطق المحتلة من قبل روسيا في جنوب
أوكرانيا ، وهذا يجعل الأمر كثيرًا
أصعب أن لا يكون مستحيلًا ، لكن
القيام بذلك أصعب بكثير نظرًا لحجم
المياه التي تأتي عبر
هذه المنطقة وأيضًا تأثير ذلك
على البنية التحتية الحالية مثل
طرق الجسور ، فأنت تعرف الأشياء
التي قد تواجهها في الوضع الطبيعي
العملية العسكرية ، نعم ، كان هذا
بالمناسبة أحد الجسور الرئيسية من
منطقة الجحيم الأوكرانية إلى
الأراضي التي يسيطر عليها الروس ، هذا الجسر أصبح
الآن غير صالح للعمل كما
تحدثت عما يعنيه هذا بالنسبة
للروس ، قال ريك إنني أريد فقط أن أشير
هذه هي شبه جزيرة القرم حيث
احتل الروس لبعض الوقت كانت هناك
قناة أيضًا تلك المنطقة اللعينة مع شبه جزيرة
القرم مصدرًا رئيسيًا للمياه لشبه
الجزيرة ، فكيف يؤثر هذا على
الروس
فيما يتعلق بالروس كما
تعلمون؟  إعادة صواب جون تمامًا في
الإشارة إلى أن القناة التي
تمد القرم بالمياه هي
مصدر مهم بالنسبة لهم أه بمجرد انقطاع هذا الإمداد
أه يجعل من الصعب
عليهم دعم أه
السكان المدنيين في أجزاء كبيرة من شبه جزيرة القرم فهذا
يعني أيضًا أن  القطعة العسكرية
أيضًا أه تعرف نوعًا ما ضعيف في هذه
المرحلة في شبه جزيرة القرم أيضًا بالنسبة للروس
أه ثم الشيء الآخر الذي
يجب أخذه في الاعتبار بالطبع هو
التأثير على القوات الروسية الموجودة
فعليًا في أه الضفة الشرقية أو
الضفة الجنوبية لنهر نيبرو
وهذا بالنسبة لهم سيكون
صعبًا للغاية لأنهم على ما يبدو لم يكونوا
يعلمون أن هذا سيحدث
ونتيجة لذلك أه أجبروا على
التخلي عن مواقعهم
لم يعودوا في  موقف لعرقلة أي
جهود أوكرانية لتجاوز هذه
المنطقة المعينة من أوكرانيا